on écoute les précisions de pauline
godard notre envoyé spécial à medica
tout près de la frontière ukrainienne
si america il ya énormément d'eau nge
énormément de bénévoles chacun met
beaucoup de coeur un pour tenter d'aider
au mieux tous ces réfugiés qui arrivent
il faut faut bien comprendre que souvent
quand ces personnes arrivent ici elles
ont passé parfois deux trois heures
voire huit heures du côté ukrainien
avant de passer du côté polonais ait
l'air est vicié assez désorienté
traumatisé fatigue et parfois on le voit
bien sur leurs visages elles ont du mal
à comprendre où est ce qu'elles sont
qu'est ce qui se passe alors il leur
faut un moment pour se poser c'est ce
qu'elle trouve ici ce moment pour se
poser pour boire un café quelque chose
de chaud pour voir se reposer sur un lit
pour les enfants également il y a des
petites salles de jeux qui ont été
aménagés et les enfants peut retrouver
un petit peu de joie de vivre pendant
pendant quelques minutes quelques heures
des cartes sim aussi sont fournies par
exemple gratuitement pour pouvoir avoir
tout de suite un moyen de communication
ici en pologne et puis il peut le voir
et aussi également un médecin nous avons
passé du temps avec pierre qui est un
médecin français volontaires ici un
médecin urgentiste
il nous expliquait être confrontée la
plupart du temps à des personnes qui
arrivent avec mal au pied mal aux jambes
mal au dos puisqu'elles ont marché
pendant des heures parfois pendant des
jours pour arriver jusqu'ici il ya aussi
beaucoup de personnes qui ont des psycho
logiquement sont traumatisés et puis
beaucoup de morsures de chiens vous
l'avez vu un depuis le début de la
guerre énormément d'ukrainiens sont
partis avec leurs animaux domestiques et
ses animaux domestiques arrive souvent
ici très stressé quand ils sont dans les
camps de réfugiés il ya énormément de
proximité ce qui serait ce encore plus
ces chiens et donc ils mordent assez
régulièrement il y a été donc décidé
depuis quelques jours enfin comme nous
l'a expliqué ce médecin que des
muselières soit distribué bien pour que
ce genre d'accident 1 arrive plus